compiling an architectural portfolio is
extremely challenging
it doesn't matter if you're doing it as
a student or somebody looking to change
jobs
i've reviewed more than i can remember
and some of these elements are
critically important for you to succeed
with your architectural portfolio
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about the key
elements that need to be in your
architectural portfolio
in order to succeed no matter what
you're creating it for
as a student or as somebody changing
jobs there are many things that we look
at in architectural portfolios
and if you stick around to the end of
the video i'm going to tell you a trade
secret
that if you do will guarantee you
success as long as you do it correctly
so it doesn't matter if you're a student
or a professional
when you're creating an architectural
portfolio the number one thing to
remember
is please make sure it is your own work
do not showcase anything anybody else
has done for you
because it becomes blatantly obvious
that this work
isn't yours at some point or another now
as a student submitting your final
portfolio or submitting for your first
job there's a couple things to remember
first of all make sure it is only one
portfolio
nobody wants to see seven packages of
different projects and
different ideas they want to see one
consolidated portfolio of your absolute
best work if it's a thesis it is only
your best work
if it's a job application it should only
be one document
that one document also needs to be
extremely tailored to the purpose for a
thesis make sure it is extremely
tailored to the marketing criteria for a
job interview make sure it's tailored to
that business
so if it's a commercial firm you're
applying for only showcase
commercial projects if it's a
residential firm again
only showcase residential projects
nobody wants to see
something that isn't relevant to them
because it's just wasting their time
now when people start flicking through
your portfolio the first thing they're
always impressed with
is render quality render quality in the
industry doesn't mean
abstract photoshop artistic imagery it
means genuine knowledge of architectural
rendering software
so if you're a gun at 3ds max or if you
know exactly how to use v-ray to create
incredible imagery showcase that you
don't want to be going and showing
generic photoshop things slap together
you
genuinely want to show as much knowledge
as you can
because your portfolio is showcasing
your skills and your abilities
the render quality only goes so far
though because if these ideas are
generic
nobody's going gonna care if you just
showcase a little baby house
in the back of some suburban village
it's gonna look nice but nobody's gonna
go wow this guy's got
incredible ideas or wow this girl knows
exactly what she's talking about
they really want to be wowed and they
want to be impressed
so whatever your abstract idea is make
sure it's grand
but make sure it is buildable from
somebody who's interviewed a number of
grads
make sure those ideas are buildable it
is the first thing i pick on grads
and it's their knowledge of
documentation nobody expects your
knowledge to be perfect but make sure
you've done some research and some
understanding of why things come
together
and how they come together so if you do
have a grand abstract master idea
be sure you know what it's being built
out of how it's going to be built
is it constructable is it feasible could
it
actually be built if it could be built
and you've documented it in such a way
that somebody could take some plans and
build it
that is incredible and something
everybody looks forward to
it doesn't matter if you're doing a
thesis or a job interview
knowing how something is constructed is
pivotal
now if you're applying for a new job and
you've already been in the profession
for a little while
you want to focus on the projects that
are completed there probably isn't too
many but a completed project
is much more valuable than one that's
theoretically still on the drawing board
anybody can go and design something
theoretically but not many people can
take the project from start to finish
if you can showcase real images real
photography and videography
of a finished project as well as the
construction documentation
of that project it's going to be
incredibly useful
because somebody who's employing you is
going to be able to go hmm
this person has documented this seen it
through to construction
gone out there visited the project kept
the connection with the client
and potentially brought in more work
later on the next key criteria
is time management and performance data
if your old work has this information on
you make sure you keep it
because understanding your performance
understanding your time management
is pivotal in your next position by
showcasing to your employer that they're
going to pay you x
but you can generate y that's 160 times
better than x
nobody wants somebody that is going to
come into the job and cost them 10 times
more than they're paying them
everybody has overheads everybody costs
a certain figure to sit in that seat
so as a new employee you want to make
sure you're generating
more money than you cost if you have
this information
it's vital i know it seems a little bit
random but
it's something that every employer and
every business owner is going to be
looking at
critically and going this guy knows
exactly what's going on now in both
situations you want to showcase at least
one page about you
it needs to be about your hobbies your
goals your aspirations
the knowledge you have behind you what
programs you know what skills you have
saying in a portfolio that you're a good
photographer
might mean to the employer that you have
a new social media content creator
or that you've been in e-commerce before
all of a sudden you know somebody that
is good at marketing
there are so many different things that
we do outside of our professional life
and in our own personal lives
that can be brought on board to be able
to better our position
so make sure you really talk about who
you are
as a person because it's just as
critical as who you are and how you
perform in that role
now because you've spent so much time
putting this portfolio together
you want to make sure the actual
portfolio is of quality
so the presentation of it needs to be
perfect one
think about a box some sort of
presentation method of how you can hand
over
this special book to the person who's
either getting the thesis
employing you in the future or that you
just want them to see
you don't want to be just handing over a
usb and going this is my work
look at it flick through the pages you
might be excited you want to genuinely
excite them with an
unboxing experience inside that box the
paper quality obviously has to be
perfect it has to be thick card
it has to be printed well if something
hasn't printed correctly go back and
print it again you don't want to be in
an interview and going oh that didn't
print right
because it shows you didn't pay enough
attention to the details
you didn't care enough to go and reprint
that that's why in university they told
you
never go to your drawing board and
scribble in your name or your student
number if you've forgotten it
because it means you didn't think about
the details everybody's going to spot
that pencil mark
but they might not necessarily spot the
mistake now if you really want to stand
out from the crowd
forget about paper completely scrap that
entire idea and forget
everything i just said i know
controversial right right now in 2021
more and more architecture is being
presented in a video format
every single day we're creating video
content just like this video that you're
watching now
to showcase to people around the world
so if somebody was to present their
thesis
or their job application to me via a
well-constructed 3d animated movie with
some
amazing footage of constructed projects
that if they're applying for a new job
for
i'd be so impressed i'd know that this
person has gone
so far above and beyond to make sure
they stand out from the crowd
everybody in the architecture industry
is good at compiling documentation
not many people are good at presenting
videos
so if you can take it a step up take it
to the next level
don't forget about the unboxing
experience and create something
incredible
this is definitely going to make sure
you stand out from the crowd anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching
i hope this video gives you some
inspiration and good guidance of how you
can create your next architectural
portfolio
if it did make sure you smash that
subscribe button below because this
video forms one of my 28 videos
in 28 days usually it would be i'll see
you next monday
but in this case i'll see you tomorrow